so there you have it folks the Metal
Gear stories finally come full-circle
Hideo Kojima kicked out of a company
Konami as they slowly back their asset
in a video games industry and for the
game itself decades-old storylines
finally getting wrapped up incredible
fictional drama mirroring that of its
real-life creators for millions of fans
around the globe this is the ultimate
end of an era the full-stop on a story
that began in their childhoods on a
curtain call for one of the most beloved
series in the history of gaming but for
others they couldn't care less the world
of video games is vast so while there
are millions of us waiting to play this
dramatic conclusion to one of our
favorite series there are millions more
that for whatever reason just don't
really care maybe they never owned the
PlayStation maybe they don't like
stealth games maybe it was just too much
of a convoluted story or perhaps they
were just too young when those early
games came out we choose our games like
we choose our meals preferences and
tastes we learn at a young age that we
trust unconditionally and for whatever
reason we just tend to absolutely trust
and live by these early preferences even
years later but why why do I still not
play Final Fantasy games why do I keep
buying fifa every year and is it wrong
that my taste in games hasn't really
changed dramatically in the past decade
today on the point why do we keep
playing the same games we love are our
brains tricking us into not playing
games that we might like and what if we
never play our favorite game
[Music]
go back in your gaming history and
remember the first games you played
maybe it was a 2d fighting game on an
old 16-bit system or a first-person
shooter on your mates PC perhaps it was
halo on your siblings console when they
came home from college or just plain old
Mario with your mom childhood is an era
of curiosity a universe full of mystery
and all the time to explore it for kids
preference happens when you're taking
your cereal but fun could come in so
many different shapes and sizes and
games when you're young well they're all
new they each have an experience worth
playing at least for a short time for
most of us growing off curiosity was
rampant there was no shortage of games
we wanted to play games we chat about
with our friends in the schoolyard and
traders we'd watch over and over but we
couldn't play them all back then our
main barrier to playing all the games we
wanted was simply cash you have to
choose your computer or console wisely
these decisions were made based on
console exclusive games the quality of
back catalogue and the dollar price on
the machine but a social element
factored in to what machine did your
friend zone with a swap games with you
picking a console your neighbor owns
suddenly unlocked dozens of new games to
play for free from a young age we were
taught something about society that
would stay with us forever everyone's in
a team and sooner or later you got a
pick which one you're in social
psychologists honorary Taj fell came up
with a reasoning for this known as
social identity theory this theory was
that we all as individuals strive for a
positive self-concept and that we do
this by associating ourselves with a
particular group we favor and as
important as being in that group is it's
equally as important to identify as
having an opposing group to look down
upon the folks who aren't part of your
group who by definition must disagree
with your choices this is what we often
refer to in gaming circles as fanboy ism
it's why Goths don't just identified by
loving metal music and black clothes in
fact their disdain of mainstream music
and clothes is equally as important this
is why the PC master-race exists and
it's why so many of us look down
casual gamers it's why people who don't
like sports are often bemused by those
who are and vice versa and even if we
don't consider ourselves fanboys it's
clear that we view the world of gaming
in this manner I can't tell you the
amount of times I've met somebody for
the first time ask them what types of
games they played and heard well I used
to be a console gamer but now I play PC
games or the other way around we so
often associate ourselves with our
groups that it's the main way of
identifying our identities and the fact
that changing your group is such a major
deal shows how important social identity
is to us as individuals but not only are
you liking to look down on those who
didn't make the same preference as you
once you've made your decision you're
gonna be even more convinced that it was
the white one choice supportive bias is
a cognitive bias in which most of us
retro actively ascribe positive
attributes that the choices were making
be that making binary choices such as
picking a turkey sandwich over beef or
buying a Playstation 4 over an Xbox one
or more sustained choices such as
dumping a lot of time or money into a
particular game or service
when considering objectively the pros
and cons of your decision your brain is
more likely to assign positive
attributes this is because in a nutshell
buyer's remorse creates anxiety so we
avoid it as much as possible justifying
every purchasing decision we make
convincing yourself that you've made the
right choice in the past is almost
easier than choosing something new like
going to the same bad hairdresser from
once on end our brains rather enjoy the
comfort of not worrying about a decision
than questioning something that feels
fine so this is all to say that we're
totally not in control of what we like
zombies robots a lot of us know
obviously there are many reasons we like
what we like in fact I still believe the
main reason that you might have a
preference for specific games has more
to do with the type of person you are
there are types of games that we find
more enjoyable or comfortable like me
would say open-world games I get that
I'm a loner who likes to explore that's
actually one of my favorite real-life
pastime cycling around my area on my own
and exploring new places what I'm
getting at is that on any given day
you're already going to buy a game that
you have a preference for like when was
the last time you listened to a new song
from a new band that you've never heard
before there's a really good chance that
your favorite song is still out there
and you've never even heard it but to do
this you have to break out of your
comfort zone and listen to
bunch of stuff you've never heard and we
forget that the same is also true of
video games it's just that the
investment whether it be time or cash
weighs more heavily games cost more they
take more time so over the course of our
lives we've just been trained not to do
it humans are comfort seeking creatures
we want to be comfortable with our
choices who we are and what we've done
so we pursue the fastest route to
happiness and entertainment something we
do to soothe ourselves is the last place
we look when being experimented on look
you don't need me to tell you that
publishers prey on this that annualized
franchises don't let you break the chain
that free-to-play is a carrot on a stick
to get you hooked in that big eSports
events gaming community blogs and
content pipelines for existing games be
them free to play or otherwise are the
pinnacle of social identity theory I
know this is entertainment than we love
what we love but there's still a really
good chance that for most of us we still
haven't played our favorite game maybe
it's in the genre you've avoided or a
series you've never tried maybe it came
out six years ago and even if it's not
your very favorite game it may be one
you loved for years to come
so then homework this week go and find
it turn off this video go to Wikipedia
open steam whatever go and find a game
to you and otherwise completely ignore
and let us know how you got on stick in
the comments below hit me up on Twitter
or send us your video impressions on the
youtubes I'm gonna do the exact same
this weekend at PAX Prime see you in two
weeks
let's go go play it if it's not swat4
then just go play swat4
[Music]
you